I think more and more information
retrieval is moving from helping people
find information to helping people get
things done I've spent a lot of my life
thinking about search it is nobody's end
goal you don't get up in the morning and
say I'm gonna search for the next two
minutes you're trying to accomplish a
task and search is a means by which you
do that and I think we shouldn't ever
forget that you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen
heusinger dr. Susan du menos you have
things to do and if you need help
finding stuff to get them done and you
probably do then her long and
illustrious career in search
technologies has been worth it situated
firmly in Louis Pasteur's quadrant of
the research grid the square where you
answer yes to both the quest for
fundamental understanding and use based
applications the Microsoft technical
fellow and deputy lab director of MSR AI
has made finding information the focus
of her career and has probably made your
life a little more productive in the
process today dr. doom a tells us how
the landscape of information retrieval
has evolved over the past 20 years
reminds us that queries don't fall from
the sky but are grounded in the context
of real people real events in real time
talks about her current interest in non
web-based search or how I can easily put
my hands on my own digital belongings
and reveals what apples and Michael
Jordan have in common with search
research that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Susan Jame welcome to the podcast
Thank You Gretchen listen I've been
waiting a long time to get you on way
back in 2017 Eric Horvitz said you gotta
get Susan on the podcast I guess you're
kind of like a hot Manhattan restaurant
you have to book two years out it's
finally come true and it's fun to be
here I like to start by situating my
guests and their research so let's get
situated
you're a Microsoft technical fellow and
the deputy managing director of
Microsoft Research AI and your work
lives at the intersection of information
retrieval and human-computer interaction
actually as we've noted its much larger
intersection than that but we'll keep it
at those two roads for now and you have
more papers patents and honors than it
would be prudent to list in a half-hour
podcast but it's worth noting that
there's a common theme running through
all the accomplishments and accolades so
tell us in broad strokes what's the
driving motivation behind the work you
do and why you do it what gets you up in
the morning I think there are two
commonalities and themes in my work one
is topical so she said I'm really
interested in understanding problems
from a very user centric point of view I
care a lot about people their
motivations the problems they have I
also care about solving those problems
with new algorithms new techniques and
so on so a lot of my work involves this
intersection of people and technology
thinking about how work practices
co-evolve with new technological
developments and so thematically that's
an area that I really like I like this
ability to go back and forth between
understanding people how they think how
they reason how they learn how they find
information and finding solutions that
work for them I mean in the end if
something doesn't work for people it
doesn't work in addition to topically I
approach problems in a way that is
motivated oftentimes by things that I
find frustrating we may talk a little
bit later about my work in latent
semantic indexing but that grew out of a
frustration with trying to learn the
UNIX operating system work I've done on
email spam grew out of frustration in
mitigating the vast amount of junk that
I was getting so I tend to be motivated
by problems
that I have now or that I anticipate
that our customers and people will have
in general given the emerging technology
trends and I approach it not just from a
us-based perspective understanding
situations it'll likely happen but also
try to generalize a bit and provide a
more theoretical and generalizable
foundation donald stokes wrote a
fascinating book about basic science and
technology innovation and he talks about
Pasteur's quadrant which is use based
fundamental research and I characterize
myself as living in Pasteur's quadrant
that's a good place to live yeah I love
the idea that you talk about things that
frustrate you and you want to solve them
because if it frustrates you probably
frustrating me too and so I'm glad to
know that you're approaching it from
that perspective that is an HCI person I
think the other thing we need to
constantly remind ourselves of is that
we're not the typical
person in fact when we started the spam
work most people didn't get a lot of
spam emails I'm motivated by things that
frustrate me I try to understand how
broadly applicable those ideas are but
there were things that frustrate me that
if I spent the you know career solving
them would not benefit lots of other
people but my work is really very much
motivated by pain points that I see
either in myself or in others or that I
anticipate seeing in technology well as
your work is anchored in information
retrieval and search let's do a little
venon now on the search landscape
because contrary to what we experienced
today high-quality search results were
not always a click away so give us a
snapshot of the field 20 years ago and
tell us how things have evolved in part
because of the work you've done over the
ensuing decades yeah you're absolutely
right if you're under 20 years of age
you have probably not lived in a world
where you don't have at your fingertips
access to an increasingly broad set of
information 24/7 even and we'll say the
mid nineties the first web search
engines were just starting and by web
search engine I mean a system that
crawls for content indexes that content
and provides it in a browser we clearly
had libraries we had library catalogs
but the ability to have at your
fingertips an amazing breadth of
information is
really fairly new some of the early
search engines things like Infoseek
AltaVista Lycos we're operating in a
very different time like us I think in
the mid nineties indexed a few hundred
thousand web pages they have a thousand
or two thousand queries a day fast
forward to today and there are billions
of web pages billions of queries per day
and so the world has evolved you know a
lot in terms of size it's evolved a lot
in terms of diversity of content mostly
the web then was HTML pages
it wasn't videos it wasn't images it
wasn't news and so more and more a
variety of different kinds of
information are there the depth of the
analysis that's provided has changed
tremendously we used to just look at
simple keywords more and more we're
going beyond keywords to do a deeper
understanding of the language the
objects the entities and think about
something like your phone when you're on
the go you're asking queries verbally
laughing that's just such a far cry from
typing in 2.1 words into a rectangle or
a mystery how its presented how you
iterate through it it's becoming much
more of a dialogue so the world has gone
from a situation where search was really
this arcane skill so you need it almost
a graduate degree in library science to
you that there were librarians we went
to them for information to a case where
today search is just ubiquitous you
expect it to be there when it's not it's
incredibly frustrating so we've gone
from something which was a real
specialty skill to something that's just
a core fabric of everything we do you
use it to find information yeah you use
it to buy things to learn about medical
conditions to learn about household or
electronic troubleshooting to find
someone you're looking for cert and that
was available in different ways through
search engines the ubiquity I think
makes it more exciting for me in many
ways it's more important to understand
people what they're trying to accomplish
and really to help them generate make
sense of and find information well
that's an amazing segue into what you're
actually doing about it because there's
a lot that went on behind the scenes
from being a very
Multi synched is something that I can
use very very easily every day and in
fact my sister to three year old
grandchild can do it better than I can
write what they call a magazine an iPad
that doesn't work right so I want to
talk specifically today about three
areas where your research contributions
have as you say built bridges among
several communities notably
human-computer interaction information
retrieval or IR and web so first let's
start with the work you did way back at
Bell Labs before you even came to
Microsoft Research in what you referred
to a little bit earlier as latent
semantic indexing or LSI so this work
addresses what's known as vocabulary
mismatch in IR systems you'll unpack
that for us I will explain the problem
first how you addressed it and then tell
us why this worked from the 1990s is
still relevant in highly high degree
yeah right century ago in graduate
school I pursued research interests in
cognitive science so a lot of my work
there revolved around building models of
how people learn and retrieve
information from their own memories and
when I moved to Bell Labs and really
started interacting much more with what
was becoming a very ubiquitous computer
industry at the time I've got very
interested in how people find
information from external sources so not
their own heads
but other people computers and one of
the problems that kept coming up over
and over and over again was this kind of
impedance mismatch between the way that
I seek information and the way that you
as an author might have written that
information it was very acute at Bell
Labs because I was trying to learn the
UNIX operating system and I wanted to
find the function that allowed me to
find a word in a document that I had and
it was called grep for generate regular
expression who in their right mind would
have done that somebody who did not
understand the broad set of users who
might wind up using those systems and so
there are two aspects of the problem and
they're both due to fundamental
characteristics of how people generate
text the first is called Sonata me that
we use
many different words to describe the
same object so you might refer to a
medical professional as a doctor or a
physician appaled means fruit and in the
last 40 years or so it's meant to
Computer Society
even people like Michael Jordan this is
very famous computer scientist named
Michael Jordan there's also a more
famous basketball player named Michael
Jordan's dad for the computer scientist
we take care of him in web search
engines okay you do and so one problem
is that there are lots of ways of saying
the same thing and the other problem
which I just mentioned is that the same
word can have many different meanings
and both of those present problems for
retrieval I think the key insight in
latent semantic indexing was that we
tried to represent words not as isolated
tokens but as a richer representation of
the contexts in which they appear so we
projected words into a much lower
dimensional space and the impact was it
brought together words that shared
similar context so physician and doctor
occur in the same company and that
allowed those words to be very similar
in this reduced dimension or what we
call semantic space there's been a
tremendous resurgence of interest in
these word embeddings or context
embeddings in the last five years or so
many of the modern word embedding
techniques whether it's word Tyvek or
glove or birth or GPT to really share
the same goal of uncovering latent
structure that problem still exists
because people write and read and
understand text and there's a tremendous
variability in that what has changed
tremendously are the data resources it's
easy to get billions of web pages
hundreds of thousands of Wikipedia pages
the computational capabilities have
increased and really the
representational richness of the models
have changed tremendously by orders and
orders of magnitude and so I think
there's been a resurgence in rethinking
what you can do with some of these
approaches
[Music]
well another area in which you and your
colleagues have made a significant
contribution is in the area of context
in search context in anything makes a
difference with language and this is
integrally linked to the idea of
personalization which is a buzzword in
almost every area of computer science
research these days how can we give
people a valet service experience with
their technical devices and systems so
tell us about the technical approaches
you've taken on context in search and
how they've enabled machines to better
recognize or understand the rich
contextual signals as you call them that
can help humans improve their access to
information if you take a step back and
consider what a web search engine is
it's incredibly difficult to understand
what somebody is looking for given
typically two to three words these two
to three words appear in a search box
and what you try to do is match those
words against billions of documents
that's a really daunting challenge that
challenge becomes a little easier if you
can understand things about where the
query is coming from it doesn't fall
from the sky right it's issued by a real
live human being they've searched for
things in the longer term maybe more
acutely in the current session it's
situated in a particular location and
time all of those signals are what we
call context they're helped understand
why somebody might be searching and more
importantly what you might do to help
them what they might mean by that you
know again it's much easier to
understand queries if you have a little
bit of context about it if I search for
Michael Jordan and you know I'm a
computer scientist that provides you a
signal if today I type in Hong Kong
Airport I probably don't want to know
about all the concessions stores in the
Hong Kong Airport I want to know about
ongoing protests there and write a lot
of searches are motivated by things that
happen in the real world and so that's
what context means just trying to
understand a little bit about where the
request is coming from what larger task
it might be embedded in what contextual
situation it might be embedded in if you
have a
single web search engine and you return
exactly the same results for the same
query to everyone at every point in time
in every location you're gonna have
suboptimal performance alright so going
a little deeper on the technical
approaches that you've taken right to
bring context
I'm leaving traces wherever I go online
I'll leave a little footprint or
fingerprint and that becomes part of
this inferred data about Who I am what
I'm doing like you said if I search the
Hong Kong Airport maybe six months ago I
wouldn't get the same results today
shortly today right what you just
highlighted is what I would call
contextualization so in that case there
are spikes and queries queries do not
occur uniformly over time and so when a
query starts spiking things like Hong
Kong Airport or Hong Kong in general
mmm-hmm
you better figure out what's going on in
many cases it's driven by external
events and that's not you as an
individual it's the aggregate of people
who are approaching search engines
asking different queries over time so
you can think about it at an aggregate
level you know at a more personal level
or in a session if you've asked a query
that's related to basketball and then
you ask about Michael Jordan that gives
you a hint about how to handle what
might be otherwise a very ambiguous
query well a third area of contribution
I want to talk about has to do with the
temporal dynamics of information this
rests on the notion that information
isn't static and when you say it out
loud it seems kind of like a no-brainer
of course it isn't static but the tools
we've traditionally used tend to focus
on snapshots of information rather than
the dynamic nature of our information so
tell us again what technical approaches
you've explored to help people interact
with the reality of dynamic information
so as you said the world is constantly
changing around us whether it's the
world of information or the physical
world in which we live in web search
what's changing is the content the web
is not static we're crawling new content
all the time that questions people ask
are changing as a function of events
that are going on in the world is a
function of events in their personal
lives
and what's most interesting is that
what's relevant changes mm-hmm so let me
just give you an example to grind the
pervasiveness if you type in the query
US Open do you mean last year or this
year it's an event or do I mean tennis
or golf exactly even if you said US Open
2019 what's relevant depends on where
you are relative to that event so right
now you're probably not interested in
the scores and results because they
don't exist you want to buy tickets
during the event you care about the
results and we've done a couple of
things to try to address that one is on
the algorithmic front so we've tried to
model things like how the content on web
pages changes we also model how people's
interactions change the queries they
issue
what's clicked on and by combining those
any kind of time series analysis you can
understand how to wait new information
versus older information right search
engines learn from people as they
interact with things that what's
relevant to a particular query but that
means new information is disadvantaged
because it doesn't have that historical
interaction data and so by being smart
and modeling things as a time series
knowing how things change over time you
can do a much better job of finding
information we also built what I think
is a really fun system it's still one of
my favorite systems it was a browser
plugin called DIF I a not a very well
named system I complained about grep
earlier this is not a lot better coming
up with dumb names exactly this was a
prototype we built to help people
understand how the world was changing
around them and what I mean by that is
the system all in the browser as you
visited a web page would look at how
that was different than the version of
the page that was in the web cache hmm
and highlight those changes to you Wow
so yeah it was a totally fun system so
imagine going to a new site and you'd
see what the changes were not relative
to what a news editor thought but since
you had last been there sure if you
hadn't been there in two days it might
be what the headlines were if you were
following a story it would just show you
what was different it really brought to
light for people how information changes
in ways that they had never seen before
right so if I would go to somebody's web
page
I might see new publications highlighted
I might see a new job title and that
really brought the dynamics to people in
ways that were really previously hidden
and so that was a really fun project
that touched not so much on the
underlying algorithms but how we can
help people understand and experience
that change the interesting thing about
the temporal dynamics of things I mean
just yesterday my husband came home and
he said there was a huge accident on 405
so I go in search accident on 405 well
five days ago seven years ago I 405 in
California it's like there's still a lot
of work that needs to be done they're
expensive that's a really interesting
trade-off between things that are a
priori really important that you want to
make sure to continue to retrieve and
the dynamics of information in that case
it's also possible that the content
wasn't there but the fact that you
thought about going to web search
suggests that you expect to find that
kind of information there and as you say
there's a long way to go in a lot of
this so you know where it led me was to
the Washington State do T Twitter feed
it is immediate you know somebody's on
that but it doesn't hit the web as News
necessarily if it's just happened in the
last half-hour right that gets to the
point of trying to integrate different
sources of information but you need to
stay on top of that how do web search
engines decide what to crawl and what
frequency to crawl it at or is some of
the information pushed this highlights a
couple of different dimensions one is
getting the data in the first place and
then how you take all this stuff from
webpages to news to maybe Twitter feeds
to structured data like Wikipedia feeds
and compose those into an environment or
representation that can really help
people solve their needs and that's much
harder if you're on a phone oh yeah
because if you have a big screen in
front of you you can show a lot of
information you can allow people's
visual systems to quickly scan it if
you're on a phone you need to take your
best guess iterate start a conversation
with people it's a much more temporal
processing of the information than a
spatial one also you look at the
generational aspect of this my daughter
rarely
was on her computer unless she's doing
something for school she's on her phone
that is her primary source and so that
data point has got to be where a lot of
researchers brains are heading is what
what is the mobile first generation how
are we going to adapt something
innovative that we did into this milieu
the world's constantly changing and you
need to evolve it we've clearly gone off
as an industry search and even beyond
that from the desktop into the real
world right and I think that raises all
sorts of interesting opportunities as
well as challenges we're not even going
to talk about hololens or any of the
other wearable technologies that I've
had other researchers in the booth about
saying hey even your phone looking at
your rectangle is going to be obsolete
sooner than you think so Susan I can
find almost any piece of general
information by searching the web but my
own information is fragmented it's
scattered everywhere on apps bookmarks
email folders devices etc tell us how
your current interest in non web search
applications it's going to help people
like me access my personal information
better right it's interesting I think
the search industry for a while was
focused actually on finding information
on your desktop finding information in
email and with the advent of the web a
lot of public information moved online
and you've seen a tremendous set of
innovations in that arena but search is
really much more prevalent and I a
particular pain point for me I told you
I was motivated by I said annoy me are
that you know we haven't done as good a
job of helping people make sense of
their own kind of personal space of
information is the way I like to think
about it in many ways that stuff you've
seen before stuff you've interacted with
its web pages it's email its documents
apps of all kinds there are so many
times when you say I know I saw this
article or I saw this photo where is it
yeah was it on Twitter was it on the web
was it on Instagram was it on Facebook
and there's no reason that you should
have to remember that and so I think the
challenge is providing people with
unified access to that information
without necessarily making copies of it
everywhere at Microsoft we are certainly
working on it from within the
Microsoft ecosystem it's increasingly
easy to find not just files but shared
files email with the click of a button
in research Shane Williams and others
have developed a prototype called task
easy that tries to improve that but it's
an area that I think still has a lot of
opportunity for improvement let me ask
you a little Oscar question sure because
this is a frustration of mine when I do
a web search and I misspell something by
accident it tells me did you mean or
looking for results for plet or on other
websites if I spell your name wrong no
results I get nothing it's a pain point
and the same was true in web search 20
years ago if you mistyped something you
didn't get anything one of the the you
didn't or you got somebody else who
randomly type things in the same way one
of the things that search engines and
lots of other web services do is
understand what people are looking for
in the ways in which they're doing it
web search engines have gotten better at
searching not because the algorithms are
better but because you can observe in
aggregate lots of people searching for
things failing to find them there were
some really interesting observations
that folks published very early on about
web search there were things that were
unexpected to people who were in the
search industry we all thought that
people would go to web search and type
in these beautiful informational
requests the most common queries at that
time in the late 90s were things like
eBay
hotmail Pokemon weather horoscope they
weren't asking for information they were
using the web to navigate things getting
back to your spelling example there were
many queries things like I think
Abercrombie & Fitch Arnold
Schwarzenegger that are misspelled more
than they're spelled correctly right but
it's learning by people typing things
incorrectly looking at their
reformulations and then figuring out how
to improve the spelling correction to
handle those cases we've talked about
personalization which in theory is
something we all want
but there's always some big trade-offs
here we'll get to the pitfalls in a
second and the discussion of the
downside of large-scale behavior
analysis but right now tell us about the
potential of large-scale behavioral
analysis that helps you contextualize
things one of the things that's happened
over the last two decades is that
web-based services whether it's a
website that you go to travel sites
shopping sites web-based services like
this because they see lots and lots of
information have provided this really
new lens onto how people are interacting
with their systems they provide insights
about how you can improve those systems
this is a lens onto people's behavior
that we just never had before even when
I joined Microsoft when I first joined
folks from office help came and said
help us because office helped search and
so my first question was what are the
most common queries and though we don't
what are people looking for we don't
know the reason they didn't know is
search for office help happened on your
desktop machine all the office help was
downloaded to your desktop all of the
searching was done on your desktop we
knew nothing about what people were
asking or whether they were being
successful because your desktop was Las
Vegas whatever happened there stayed
there exactly my desktop is a little
cleaner than Las Vegas but you know in
the minute they moved office search on
to the web you learned all sorts of
things and so by knowing what people are
seeking doing we can create the relevant
content we can create the relevant
algorithms and so this has been an
amazingly rich lens this virtuous
feedback cycle between delivering
content and using it to understand what
it is that people are looking for and
where the failure points are it's hard
to understate how much systems have
really changed because of that
[Music]
well like a recurring nightmare what
could possibly go wrong right and you've
done a lot and seen a lot over the
course of your career one thing is a
great interest to me is this idea that
in order to help us get better search
results and I want that I want
personalization on the one hand but the
things I have to give up about my own
personal information my privacy I'm
given up to the web to help you make my
search better so you talked about the
potential pitfalls here because I know
you're thinking about them what keeps
you up at night yeah sure in general
there's really a need to balance in a
very thoughtful and responsible way the
benefits that accrue from seeing various
kinds of interaction understanding how
people are interacting with systems and
the potential risks for storing
information about individuals that
enable these services for some of the
things that we talked about in terms of
spelling correction the fact that there
were navigational queries that people
had not anticipated those happen at the
aggregate level and frankly a lot of the
insights happen at the aggregate level
or group level and some of them happen
at the individual level but many of them
happen at a much higher level we all
make these trade-offs every day you know
I give credit card information to some
services because it's easier for me
mm-hmm I want to save my purchase
history in some places because it's once
easier to go back and refine things and
I think you know as a company Microsoft
is tremendously invested in protecting
people's privacy the security of
information that people entrust us with
so I think as an industry what we need
to do is work first and foremost to
protect whatever data we have also to be
clear on what information is being
stored be transparent about it and
provide people with ways of opting out
of that when I type in the beginning of
a name I would like it to autocomplete
sure when I move to a new computer where
that's not the case I find it
frustrating and again there are ways
that that data can be store
word over different time horizons it can
be aggregated and anonymized I think
search engines in particular but really
almost any web service tries to strike
the right balance between understanding
things at a very fine level and then
aggregating things where that's relevant
inappropriate all right it's story time
I happen to know you didn't start out
thinking I'm gonna be a computer
scientist or the deputy lab director of
MSR AI so tell us how it all began for
you maybe not back to when you were a
baby but you know kind of academically
and how you landed here at MSR in your
leadership role today well what you just
said is certainly true Microsoft didn't
exist when I was in high school and in
graduate school so I had no aspirations
of being there if I did I would be
incredibly wealthy right now
yeah would I look back on my career I
think it's fun to reflect on a few pivot
points because the road from where I was
as a high school student in
undergraduate in Maine to Redmond
Washington in the tech industry is not
one that I had planned for men to end
and I was able and lucky enough to be in
environments where I could take some
risks and take some turns so let me just
tell you a few of them that really stand
out in my mind I started college as a
math major intending to go to law school
I've wanted to do environmental law I
took a course when I was a junior called
mathematical psychology which was a
course that talked about how people
learn information how they recall
information how you can precisely
describe the evolution of learning and
retrieval of information from memory and
I was just smitten I just thought it was
the most fascinating thing blending
algorithms with the ability to
understand people and how they weren't
and so I just decided that I was gonna
go to psychology graduate school I had
no idea what it was my parents were even
more concerned but I did it I had a
blast doing it and then when I finished
my PhD I had every intent of teaching at
a university and when I was looking for
jobs I got a call from Bell Labs and
they had just started the industry's
first human-computer interaction lab and
I was still all set on going to a
university and my undergraduate advisor
called and said I hear you're going
to Bell Labs and I said no I don't think
so and he literally said you ought to
have your head examined and I asked why
and he made a very good point which was
you really have nothing to lose by this
and a lot to gain here at the beginning
of something that could be a really
important future direction and if you
decide you don't like it you can leave
and two years later you'll be better off
than you are now in looking for jobs and
almost forty years later you can say
that it suited me very well in my
transition from Bell Labs to Microsoft
was also based on opportunities that I
decided to seize we had had a postdoc at
Bell Labs who was a product manager in
office at the time on find fast and he
said hey Microsoft Research is looking
for somebody in information retrieval I
told them they should reach out to you
and again I am NOT looking to move but I
came I really enjoyed meeting the people
the problems the scale of problems I
could just see being very very different
from what I had and again that nav 22
years later it's been maybe one of the
best decisions in my life in part
because what I'm interested in helping
people create find manage make sense of
information is exactly what Microsoft is
about right so every question I have
every innovation I have has really
natural outlet so I find that really
gets sort of exciting and fun MSR is
also just this amazingly vibrant
intellectual environment that I love
people from lots of different
perspectives coming together well as we
close and I'm sad that we're closing
because you're fun there are a handful
of people who've really earned the right
through length depth and quality of
career to give advice to people then
you're one of those people let's frame
the final question in terms of your
leadership role in cultivating the next
generation of talent here at MSR tell
our audience from your perspective
what's on the horizon in the field and
why is now a good time to be a
researcher when I think back on my
career and I look at other successful
people I think we all share some traits
that I think are important to think
about one is to have a purpose
but also be willing to seize a new
opportunity and I just told you several
times how many really pivotal points in
my life came from having a true north
but also be willing to take not the
obvious and straight path to it so Jack
Sparrow's compass exactly no no actually
not where ever I had a goal but I was
also willing to deviate when there were
opportunities the second is to be
passionate about what you do I think I'm
incredibly fortunate to be an
environment where my passion and what
people pay me to do a line but in any
endeavor you're going to work hard
you're gonna work long hours find
something that speaks to you it might be
an application area it might be a
particular theoretical framework of
methodology but make sure that at the
end of the day when you've worked really
hard you're proud of that outcome and
perhaps the most important thing is to
persevere be persistent in what you do
there is no straight path to an
aspiration and how you get there and I
think it's often deceptive because
students will see this brilliant talk by
somebody who's very well known in the
field this person is just brilliant sure
they may be brilliant but they've also
worked hard behind the scenes they've
tried lots of things that failed and I
think it's really important to stick
with it and learn from failures but also
celebrate successes in terms of I think
some of the interesting areas moving
forward let me just mention three one of
them is that I think more and more
information retrieval is moving from
helping people find information to
helping people get things done I've
spent a lot of my life thinking about
search it is nobody's end goal you don't
get up in the morning and say I'm going
to search for the next two minutes
you're trying to accomplish a task and
search is a means by which you do that
and I think we shouldn't ever forget
that so really trying to go from finding
information to using that information in
a way that helps you solve the problem
the other one we mentioned briefly
before it's moving off the desktop into
the world more and more our systems are
interacting there's this interesting mix
of
digital in physical worlds and I guess
the last it's a personal one I think
there are really interesting
opportunities moving forward to combine
insights from computation cognitive
science and neuroscience it's an area
that I haven't had as much time to spend
as I would like but I think there's some
interesting things coming together in
that space you know I'm glad that you're
passionate and persistent about what
you're doing because it's helped my life
in many many ways you're right I don't
get up and say I'm gonna go search I
have to find something and I need that
click to be the one I want Susan do you
may thank you so much finally for coming
on the podcast thank you it's really
been fun to talk with you to learn more
about dr. Susan Dumais and how the
search for better search goes on
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]